when you sort of create a robust healthy
human then you know you can tolerate
more of these things that doesn't mean
you should holler you should force
yourself to tolerate them but right you
know in many of the people that we work
with you know cutting out alcohol
altogether to begin with is very
important but then adding some of that
back in can certainly have benefits for
multiple reasons
can we talk about CBD and THC we both
live in states where that's legal now
yeah and I can tell you I first started
doing CBD oil last year and just to help
out with with sleep I've heard people
talk about you know it's good for back
pain and all this other stuff and I
found the curcumin is actually way way
better for back pain than the CBD oil
was for me although I haven't tried the
lotions and stuff like that but then
also THC and edibles especially like the
OL spray or like a vape pen before going
to bed I found that that helps me out a
little bit with sleep if I'm if I'm
struggling with sleep so I know there
are obvious upsides and downsides I like
to get some opinions on this we asked
some data we don't even need it and we
were we were actually talking about this
over breakfast that's the kind of guys
that we are yeah so the interesting
thing is that CBD on its own based on
the data that's available should not
help with sleep so basically when
they've looked at it and they've given
people CBD alone or CBD plus THC the CBD
alone can actually cause alertness and
it may be to do with how CBD and THC
affect cortisol metabolism there's some
other stuff of it you know the the
signal the ways they signal you know so
some people may sleep worse if they take
CBD and but when you add THC then people
seem to sleep better so there's like a
there's a synergism there however I can
say for personal experience that I've
tried CBD alone before bed and it
certainly seems to help it certainly
does seem to help me sleep and why that
is I actually I actually don't know I
don't have a study to say this is why I
think there's the you know there's gonna
be an interaction with all the other
things that are going on in the gut CBD
has certainly been shown or you know to
improve got information got health I
don't think that's an issue for me but
that's particularly animal studies and
now it's been
translated CBD is now being used for in
cancer therapies and for epileptics and
they're starting to use it in people
with inflammatory bowel disease so can
certainly have a number of benefits I
haven't tried the CBD plus THD THC was
more of a thing I did in my teenage
years but but have both been shown
potentially to help with sleep the the
potential downsides are obviously then
can interfere with cool summers harbors
and all this other stuff so if it's not
causing it if it's not causing you
benefit then you know there's no there's
potential downsides for taking it so I
mean we do think you know particularly
for people you know heavy marijuana
users there is some risk of mental
health issues if that's coming from THC
or other things you know of is obviously
the the strength the concentration of
THC in marijuana has increased
dramatically over the last few decades
so there's there's multiple factors that
play there if you're taking 10
milligrams of THC with 30 milligrams of
CBD before bed you know you're probably
well under that that risk first hold but
there are studies that show that it
interferes with hormone metabolism
called slow metabolism so it's just it's
at the moment is kind of a try it out
and see if it benefits you but equally
you know we roll back to our continuous
message which is why aren't you sleeping
in the first place right you don't want
to medicate yourself to sleep you want
to find out what it is it's causing your
poor sleep in the first place similar to
the melatonin in the apple meadow that
can help but but that is a band-aid off
the band-aid that you not having enough
melatonin because you're exposing
yourself to bright lights at night all
you know it's something like that right
and so I think the micro dose with are
the few times where I've done edibles
where I get a like oh I can't do
anything else besides eat potato chips
today I just I don't like the feeling
and so I I tend to I tend to avoid avoid
that but I also have found that the
mental health thing so I have the mental
health problems running my family my dad
was schizophrenic my brother was
schizophrenic killed himself
and so I know like that's the reason I
won't do psilocybin and other things
because there's a potential for you know
even though I think I'm well past the
age at this point where those symptoms
would present themselves I do notice
that the couple times where I've tried
that an edible that is like Oh like this
is too much the next day I it's like the
roller coaster there you can't have the
high without the low sort of thing and
the entire next day I'm just like oh
wait I should be happy right now but I
cannot be happy this is a thing this is
a story for anything that you take to
try and change the way your brain
functions but what we usually say is
there's no biological free lunch right
you can't ask your brain to do something
which you wouldn't normally do and then
expect it to be completely normal after
so nootropics are a classic example you
know you take these compounds are
supposed to increase brain cognitive
function various brain functions but it
might increase function in one area but
it makes you less good in another area
and then so maybe well I will do I'll
take a nootropic usually book the only
time I do is before a podcast yeah and I
know in afternoons I all I have this
brush yeah yeah there is a nootropic
crash for me I thought maybe I was
unique in that because I've never heard
anyone else talk about it but no I'm
certain if experience the same and there
are some some nootropics that are
basically just like the kitchen sink
everything's in there and this sort of
light switches everything on you
definitely notice a difference but then
you gotta come down later so I often
liken it to taking MDMA where your
lights switch everything on you feel
great and then you know a few hours
later you have this you have this big
come down and it's not the same for
everybody again it's something that you
have to experiment with yourself but but
you know again we go back to why isn't
your brain functioning as you would like
it to why do you feel the need to take
something to enhance your brain function
are there other things you could be
fixing and therefore you don't need to
take that it's propak in the first place
you know that's always where we're gonna
go back to and then if you know
occasionally you need to try something
like that you just need to be aware
they're asking your body or brain to do
something you wouldn't normally do
you might gonna you're gonna pay for it
later yeah from either the THC thing is
not to a point where it's or at least
that I feel there's any sort of
psychoactive effect it
it's it's like micro dosing that's like
one or two milligram sort of thing and
the thing that helps me with is with the
sleep is it prolongs the the period
where I stay asleep another thing that
has really helped me and I I've had to
get really sort of diligent about it and
I screw up still all the time water I
drink a lot of water during the day but
I stop at 5:00 p.m. I stop drinking
liquids of 5:00 and that way I don't
feel compelled to get up at 3:30 a.m. to
pee
which but sometimes when that happens I
get up at 3:30 a.m. and I'm like I'm up
I can't get back to sleep now and so I
found those two things for me in the
water is probably way more helpful than
the THC to be honest with you so just
something to think about any other words
about THC no it's not something that
really interested me on the c-word site
about the stuff that's free like
sunshine I'm very excited about where as
yeah sunshine deficiency can definitely
cause insomnia so like you can fix that
first before having to buy a supplement
we so we the one reason why we talk
about CBD is because again it might help
with people with inflamed guts and we
see a lot of those so we know a lot of
people who feel they've benefitted from
taking you for some see yeah so that's
an interesting thing that you bought up
recently is that maybe you have some
problem that's stopping you from
sleeping and then you take another thing
that makes that first problem worse and
maybe introduces another problem but the
net effect is still positive and so your
sleep does get better yeah
you